I was this movie worth watching just for
the Twilight jab it hasn't it yeah kinda
Hotel Transylvania
so Hotel Transylvania is an animation
and it has the voices of Adam Sandler
and Andy Samberg you remember them no
that was like Jack and Jill or anything
like that but I'm just saying the
premises Adam Sandler's Count Dracula
who makes his Hotel for monsters and
drag ulis daughters turning 118 so I
guess in vampire years that's like
eighteen to us she wants to go out and
see the world she's really curious but
he's really protective cuz he's like nah
humans are crazy and they're gonna kill
you which is one of the funny aspects of
this movie all these monsters come to
this hotel so you see them all they got
Bigfoot they got the blob Wolfman The
Mummy Quasimodo although it's kind of
messed up to call him a monster he's
just a dude with a deformity it'd be
nice but the way they see humans is like
how humans see monsters you know they're
like not that come at you with these
crazy eyes with pitchforks and torches
they want to kill you that kind of
perspective just made me chuckle I was
like yeah that's pretty smart so anyhow
in Hotel Transylvania this really
adventurous human ends up stumbling onto
their Monster Mash which is a graveyard
smash but he's a human and Dracula finds
out about it and if any of the monsters
find out about it they'll probably kill
him so he has to make the monsters
believe that this dude is actually a
monster also but he's the life of the
party because Dracula throws some really
boring ass parties so Dracula wants him
to leave everyone else wants him to stay
and Dracula has to hide the fact that
he's a human from the monsters makes for
a pretty surprisingly funny premise
actually I actually enjoyed this
animation the premise was ludicrous it
was really funny I felt it was well done
some of the jokes started to delve into
some lowbrow Adam Sandler humor but then
the movie focuses and it becomes
enjoyable again nice about Dracula who's
this really overprotective father from
his daughter who wants to go out and
enjoy life and be adventurous but she's
a vampire and her in the human start
developing this romance which isn't
remotely as cheesy as some vampire
romances out there did I enjoy this
movie yes I did was it funny yes it was
is it some relevant animation that's
made for adults and kids no but adults
can watch the movie when they take their
kids to see it not want to shoot
themselves in the face if I were dumb
enough to have a kid I would be like III
take him to this movie it'd be no
problem he'd enjoy it I'd enjoy it I say
he because I would have a son because
that's just what I would demand
how many if you're gonna have a kid make
sure it's awesome I mean I enjoyed this
movie and it's ultimately an Adam
Sandler movie so here it is Adam Sandler
you're no longer allowed to make
live-action movies that time is done it
is gone make animations like Hotel
Transylvania or other Hotel Transylvania
movies and people will not want to hate
you this might be your niche man just
roll with it I will say Hotel
Transylvania is a good time no alcohol
required cuz you don't want to booze it
up when you take your kid to a movie a
douche that in the movies pretty
enjoyable alright so your favorite movie
monster who is he she or it whoever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more